charlie munger wasn't too happy about
crypto yeah he heard the comments that
he made about matter of fact i'll read
it to you guys to see what he had to say
about crypto first time agreeing with
what china is doing
charlie munger who's a partner warren
buffett he's a billionaire goes off on
crypto says china made the right
decision when they banned it this is a
fortune story for all the recent buzz
surrounding crypto investment charlie
munger is just not buying it and he
doesn't want any crypto traders marrying
into his family either believe me the
people who are getting into
cryptocurrency are not thinking about
the customer they're thinking about
themselves just look at them i wouldn't
want any of them to marry into my family
he also said that he supports china's
crack crackdown
on cryptocurrency and frowned upon the
us's heavy involvement with it the
chinese made the correct decision which
is just simply banned them and he
slammed bitcoin specifically of course i
hate the bitcoin success i don't welcome
a currency that's so useful to
kidnappers and extortionists and so
forth nor do i like
just shuffling out of your extra
billions of dollars to somebody who just
invented a new financial product out of
thin air so
obviously you agree with charlie but you
want to go a little bit deeper into what
he says
totally fair to say i agree with him but
but but i think his comments are
important because remember in my book i
have a whole section on how crypto came
to be okay so it's very important that
people realize i mean back when bitcoin
was a dollar i knew about it so
what you have to understand is the value
of the coin
and the platform are mutually exclusive
and what that means is is that the
platform is very important to understand
blockchain technology is how you will
transact all business in the future like
you buy a piece of property right now
you have a title agent you have doc
stamps you have a little lady that's
pressing your thing down into the county
it's very it was never meant to be a
speculative currency exactly so so when
people talk about investing in crypto
they're not investing okay they're
speculating that the value of the coin
is going to go up and they're going to
sell it to somebody else who's going to
want the coin there's like 10 000 coins
i mean coin gecko or whatever the site
is ten thousand coins okay these are
useless
utterly useless now what percentage are
you using that's a high high percentage
that's true a high percentage
ninety percent
i would say if you really want to own
crypto you own ethereum first you own a
little bit of bitcoin and you leave the
rest alone like none of it
because did i make the ethereum argument
last week i want to see why he's going
to say that makes you curious because
you take okay a smart contract like like
with your house you have title insurance
what is title insurance it says that
that if there's a problem with the title
later that they'll ensure that you
actually bought the title and whatever
that's all solved by blockchain so like
smart contracts you're talking about
there's a zero value for title insurance
10 years from now the currency is the
contract too it's like when pat was
buying his house and it was a three-day
process for him to sign the deal that's
now just the coin that's right so what
should gerard do with all his dogecoin
though
well that's that's
that's a that's
who knows right because remember musk
comes out and makes dogecoin a thing
now it's not a thing it's gone he said
it was a not a scam but it was a
so what do you say on snl but look
that's like stock promotion i mean
imagine if somebody it's weird right
it's weird you come out and you're like
you know what if my company's metallic
or some mta if i was like you know
metallo's uh if i started saying all
these things about how it's gonna go to
the moon right the sec shuts me down i
can't be on a board i can't say anything
unless you're in congress then it's fine
well yeah it's very cool by the way this
is a very good point here this is a very
good point he's making you can't go
claim that your stock or an investment
is going to go to the moon but you can
with crypto yeah and a lot of people do
that yeah that's true
think about it the rock came out
tomorrow and was like shiba you know to
the moon and he owns a million shebo's
and it goes up one decimal point he's a
deca billionaire this goes back to the
joseph kennedy model back in the days
when he made the stock market uh crash
and fdr brought him in because he knew
all the ways of manipulating the stock
market and then they added controls to
it so the challenge with the crypto
community that they come back and they
say well the government cannot touch it
they've already been trying to touch it
and then i get some of the private
equity guys that say let me tell you
what people are doing in private equity
right now because the tax code with
crypto you can buy take a loss buy again
you can do double tax write-offs over
and over and they're not going to let
that last too long of a title isn't that
the beauty of the market like school
costs money man if you get caught in the
pump and dump you get caught once okay
it happens yeah twice that's all you you
i'm not disappointed one shame on you
but what i'm trying to say to you is you
really believe in elizabeth warren and
aoc of bernie sanders a nancy pelosi is
going to allow that to happen you think
they're going to let that happen
constantly in the crypt you don't think
these guys are eventually going to want
to over regulate the crypto community of
course i do but they're trying now and
they can't figure it out they're getting
you used to this so everybody is
accepted the fact that they can have a
wallet they can have digital money all
their money can be on the grid all these
people to talk about cryptos off the
grid they're completely wrong like the
kid in orlando that was hacking people's
twitters remember and taking yeah of
course they caught him they showed up at
his house yeah how did they do that i
found him like very quickly very quickly
and he had sent the bitcoin all over the
world to be split and washed this is on
the grid anybody who thinks they're off
the grid just needs to research why
because they're on platforms like
coinbase or
gemini
the blockchain is infinitely traceable
and controllable and where this is which
is the point of the blockchain correct
where this all ends is fedcoin and in
the book this is this is a term that i
came up with about six years ago fedcoin
is what we'll use to pay for everything
and it'll be easy to get people accepted
and what i think this is somewhat
controversial but i think all these
stable coins
ultimately are going to crash and then
fedcoin will be what they bring like the
phoenix they bring out of this they're
saying like the tether the u.s that's
right i think those are going to crash
and then it's all just going to be and i
think it might be pre-designed crash
where basically
they say okay everyone's into this now
all right but as you can see there were
some speculative problems like the
private market so the fed will control
this but wait do you think some shadowy
international pseudo government would
organize some sort of doomsday event
never to increase never
never but imagine if you if we are the
elite okay so we say right now okay we
would let people be free but nonsense
because what happens when you get to
that level is you try to consolidate
power all the time you're worried about
threats and so look at fedcoin i can
control everything you do taxation you
can no longer avoid being taxed because
all of your money is on the so they're
going to nationalize crypto is what
you're saying in other words they'll
pick a crypto winner that's infinitely
you know the blockchain is distributed
ledger that's the technology but when
you have fedcoin it's controlled ledger
so mit makes one server that controls
the entire fedcoin ecosystem on a
quantum computer and every single
fedcoin is documented and you you've
been really naughty so no more leisure
activities oh yeah with your social uh
social engineering your social studies
okay so let me ask you so let's just say
we go in that direction who wins who
loses
well i think people that are close to
power win okay what we're transitioning
to is a command economy so this is what
china has and i think the us is envious
of china because china's control is so
great command economy yeah a command
economy so in a command economy where
you want to be is opposed to a market
economy is that the that's long gone so
in in a market economy there's price
discovery and what happens is that price
discovery creates the value of
everything and the market it produces
different solutions you know to solve
different problems we left that behind a
long time ago right now command economy
is is controlled by fiat it's controlled
by committee and if you look at how
things are going in the u.s the
narrative comes out the news story
narrative comes out the policy is set
and then people like us say we debate
about these things but it's it's
pointless because is this like a
communism rebrand a command economy
communism trying to be it's trying to be
uh communism with the idea of free
market principles because if you look in
america everybody's like oh this is a
this is a free market is it really a
free market i mean
oh we can vote here it's really it's
really this is great because we choose
our elected leaders do we really choose
our elected leaders at every turn all
the things people say
if you really question them so let me
ask you they're falling apart i i'm
sensing a
threat here similar to peter schiff so
are you saying
we stopped being a
market economy free enterprise where you
can go out there and do everything when
it was based on a gold standard and now
it's a command economy because it's
based on fiat are you going to the 1972
no is that kind of where you're going no
no and peter's a friend i mean he's he's
our our biggest shareholder in our
company you know he's really a trip to
hang out with because he's he has a
different take on this that than i have
i mean so i don't think the gold
standard really matters that much i mean
the government has you know
nuclear-powered
aircraft carrier battle groups and they
tell you this is the dollar and okay
it's the dollar i i call it the lead
standard yeah we're on the led stand
yeah exactly that's what we're gonna
we're gonna use spedcoin they can do the
same thing you say you use fed core and
you starve i mean that that's the deal
you know like you're going to do it so
what happens to the actual u.s dollar if
this fed coin comes to existence i don't
think it matters i mean i think what we
see is like interest rates started
falling at the turn of the century like
they're negative right now they're going
to keep going down everybody's like oh
they're going to go up the government's
going to have a hard time financing
itself no it's not going to happen it's
not going to happen the deal is you can
control this this is a controlled
demolition so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]